I hope you're sitting down because I'm
about to rock your world did you know
that Vegeta wasn't always the prince of
all Saiyans it seems pretty crazy to
think about right now given how Central
it is to his character alone but taking
a look back in the manga yourself and
you will see that him being a prince was
never mentioned in the Saiyan Arc this
detail was in fact a retroactive part of
his character introduced in the Frieza
Arc before then it was only ever
mentioned that Vegeta was of a high
Prestige and the strongest Saiyan could
you imagine if Toriyama hadn't invented
that bit of lore Vegeta would go on to
fight boo years later going on about how
he was not the prince of all Saiyans but
a rich and Powerful Saiyan at least
little Posh boy Vegeta isn't that cute